[Music]
the thing that I want good I bring most
from my culture is congeniality meaning
that forever smile and always choosing
to focus on the best you know in
anything and I think that's what
Jamaicans have been known for all these
years is the that's thing about smile no
matter what
Troy Lopez is the chef and Kirk Henry
the manager the two men run Rosa Caleta
which is named after their grandmothers
the two Jamaicans met in the early 1990s
in Paris Henry grew up in Jamaica
studied business and worked in various
jobs Lopes left Jamaica in 1981 and
studied literature in Paris he's lived
in Berlin since 1990 after all these
years in Berlin I feel at home it's a
place where people come visit me my best
friends are also right here in Berlin
decent here in value it's minor the
Susannah guns [ __ ] was only visiting at
the start now he's a Berliner well yet
since ein Berliner
in 2009 the two friends opened Rosica
letter in the Kreutz birth district
which is known as a melting pot of
people from various backgrounds and
cultures more than a hundred thousand of
them have an immigrant background
many have Turkish roots Kreuzberg is
also popular with students and artists
the restaurant in Kreuzberg that was
definitely because Kreuzberg was the
cool place to be Berg was in some terms
a sort of homecoming it was really um
just so easy to be here in every way
just do what you want to do be who you
want to be you know act how you want to
act and do what you want to do in the
beginning Rosa Caleta was supposed to be
more of a community center with a small
menu but nowadays the restaurant has a
reputation for great Jamaican food with
an international influence
Henry and Lopez both grew up with their
grandparents that continues to influence
them today - gross smoother well my
grandmother was an important person in
my life ago it doesn't matter that she
has been dead for a number of years
she's still alive for me when I think of
a dish I think about how it tasted when
she made it
he had duska Schmeck Aziz's cook october
if stenka this is this is how I think
this place has a grandmotherly feel what
a fool gift here well this is a
restaurant based on our grandmother's
Lopez took cooking lessons in Paris and
did internships in various other
restaurants my favorite Jamaican saying
is take a hand to can turn fashion it
means take what you have and make
something of it that's what I'm doing
for example we don't use any shallots in
Jamaica because we don't have any I
discovered that a mix of shallots and
green onions produces a taste that's
like the red spring onions we have on
the island Maki with salt fish is a
traditional Jamaican dish
[Music]
usually it's eaten for breakfast or
lunch or as an appetizer for dinner the
basic ingredients in Caribbean cooking
are fresh vegetables spices and fish
salt fish is usually made of Cod link or
[ __ ]
packing is jamaica's national fruit you
can only buy it in cans in Europe a
fleshy part is very delicate and needs
to be treated with care
ackee and saltfish is a dish served with
salad plantains and dumplings
the two restauranteurs say that they
serve fusion food the Caribbean
specialities in Rosa Caleta always have
a European influence today I made a key
and sawfish for you the Jamaican
national dish Bon Appetit